if you are sitting on a great idea it is
time to turn it
into a reality with guess who
squarespace
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project if you want to
showcase your work or if you want to
sell products of any kind
and they have beautiful templates that
give you the ability to customize just
about
anything so you can make a website all
by yourself but if you get stuck
don't worry they have 24 7 award-winning
customer support
that is there to help head to
squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i am your fraggle
of a host grace ann helbig it's a very
exciting episode not too deep today's
guest
is none other than bob saget yeah
you heard me it happened and now it's
happening to you
this is some real big dad energy
on this episode of not too deep that i
think you'll really enjoy because
i for sure did that man can't help but
exude
paternal nurturing we talk all about his
start in comedy
uh from a a 17 or 18 year old boy
winning
a comedy song contest on the radio
to becoming the danny tanner that we all
knew and shaped all of her collective
childhoods to
now where he's at using social media
starting his own podcast where he's just
cold calling anyone that wants to talk
to him and having
really fascinating conversations um
this episode in the midst of everything
crazy in the world
provided a little bit of calming comfort
for me and also was a little silly we
got it i mean it's bob saget
it's bob saget on not too deep i hope
you guys enjoy this episode
i definitely did enjoy bob saget on not
too deep
[Music]
bob thank you for being here this is
very exciting
it's obviously strange times but i
appreciate the time you're taking to
talk to us
and i appreciate that your uh
perspective
is to stay true to
the entertainment side of you and the
ability
like the the superpower that you have to
create a space where people can distract
themselves in
a fun and uh hopefully healthy way
yeah you're doing i appreciate what
you're doing grace because
it's about because it's a there has to
be an outlet for people to go somewhere
to have a
place of solace whether it be their
their narrative television show
and away from everything we've been
feeling and watching and living and um
yeah i've been um i've gotten really
into scrabble go
on my phone it's been uh an extremely
helpful app but my screen time on my
phone is now up to like eight and a half
hours a day
is your battery dying more have you
found it constantly
emotionally and on my phone yes both are
dying
do you think forgive me do you think
it's busy or because
you're so busy or you're so much younger
than me that you just let it die
because my wife no lets her phone die
she she's busy she's busy
i'm not one of those i'm constantly
having it plugged in so i feel like the
battery drains faster but i
am charging it more often because having
less than like 50
battery on a phone to me is very
terrifying i i don't know how people can
let it go down to where it turns yellow
or red
it's like an empty refrigerator you
can't you have to keep it replenished
yeah but but i feel like you feel like
um
we can have our feelings and we're
hurting and we're we're feeling and
uh i always feel for humanity i i'm
always
a general lover of uh as much as
possible and i can't understand
i can't understand hatred i just can't
um
and i just want to make people feel good
i just want some help
there is a sense that i think all
comedians and performers
have a deep love for humanity obviously
because
your job is to kind of scrutinize it
experience it and process it through
your own you know point of view and lens
and then
also be validated by the people that
make up humanity
for your observations on it so it's
obviously
you want the best for humanity always
always
all humanity because i don't understand
how you
but put people in cubicles i don't get
how you uh were you an outsider in
school as a kid were you one of those
i was a very quiet shy kid
um i was very much like i think a lot of
people that i went to high school with
didn't know
that i went to high school with them i
was one of those were you very shy or
were you more outspoken i was both
i was really popular when i was four and
five peaked no i peaked at about uh
11 i was hilarious and then i found i
lived in norfolk virginia so then i
found out what the world was like
yeah she started to get persecuted for
being a kid
that they persecuted um and it was
because of my religion i mean um
i'm uh what am i i'm i'm a sagittarius
no i'm a uh
i was i'm a jewish guy so uh they would
make fun of that and
and it was it was really painful and and
that that affected me i'm very sensitive
so
do do you remember actively or do you
have a memory of the first time
you thought comedy was
powerful or comedy was something that
was interesting to you more than other
things yeah i knew it about
four that it would make people like me
so that i would
do funny things without probably the
most obnoxious things
and then and a lot of comedians i've
talked to and i've known because i'm so
old i've known someone
but uh there are older people that we
thank god but i
but a lot of the comedians like richard
pryor and ronnie dangerfield
it was survival it was literally their
survival
so yeah um they um rodney used to say
you do six minutes for the guard at the
border in germany
and then the jewish guy can get out if
he's funny if you can make the guard
laugh
so i tried to make people laugh
but then i got so insecure when i was 13
14 and then i moved to california so
then i got all screwed up and then i
moved again
between 11th and 12th grade so my senior
year was in philly
and then i went to college in philly so
i was
always an outcast and so i became a
stand-up at 17 years old
didn't know i was gonna be one really
yeah i was gonna ask
what was the first thing that prompted
you to say i'm gonna go try this
i wrote comedy songs and i'd seen people
i snuck in and saw
um don rickles in atlantic's you know in
uh in
new jersey i believe that's a it's not
atlantic city it was
i think it was camden and i'm from new
jersey originally
but yeah yeah yeah where
south jersey my dad my stepmom live near
atlantic city
uh and then my mom and step dad live
across the bridge from philadelphia i
that's
my life that's my whole life um and
i uh won a radio contest with wmmr
at 17 i wrote a song about bondage
okay so you had seen some things in your
lifetime
the question what happened to bob why
did he get like that why isn't he danny
tanner was
i wrote a song about bondage when i was
17.
there was it wasn't a big leap danny
tanner was the facade
it's an actor it's a part yeah but uh
you know it's
finally gonna go away right right right
like so it's like star trek so at 17
you write this song you win a radio
contest
you you feel that first surge of like
validation
the thing that like you all search for
and did from there did you start like
actively seeking stand-up shows
and not not i didn't do it on purpose i
i
i i went to film school at temple
university i was originally in pre-med
i wasn't going to be a comedian i wanted
to be a doctor i couldn't
pass a course i couldn't do i couldn't
do chemistry i couldn't do bio i
couldn't do anything
and i even had a religion course and i
was like i can't read all these books
i got to make movies and then i made a
film and i won the student oscar for a
movie i made so they
fooled me and then at the same time
those four years
i was doing improv at university of
pennsylvania with friends even though i
wasn't a student
and then in their big show they have
mask and wig there and a thing called
all-star review
and that's their hasty pudding type
thing but it's it's an ivy league
comedy thing and so i was allowed to be
in some of that
and um i did improv and i made movies
and i did stand up i did like five
things just like i do now
yeah direct direct movies uh
documentaries things i wasn't in
and then i made some terrible i mean 60
hours of horrible things
and that's the quicker you can make
terrible things is as fast as you can
make something good
yeah yeah that's true that's what i what
i hope
and um and then when i moved to la i was
going to go to usc grad school and mitzi
shore
said no work at the comedy store so i
did
and i i was there for eight years
emceeing and
met everybody all the all the greatest
comedians
of that home since 1978 and uh
and that's it and then i just found out
that i'm a stand-up
and then i started touring right away
and opening for people right away
but i struggled i still lived in a
single apartment in palms what's what's
your deal now i know you've talked about
it on here a lot but
oh sure uh my the abbreviated version of
my deal is
uh similar i went to college in northern
new jersey
i got into comedy i started taking
improv classes at the people's improv
theater in new york
because i was able to intern there
and ucb had a waitlist for their
internship so people's improv theater
was like can you start friday i was like
great done
uh and then took some editing classes in
college
but didn't really know what i wanted to
do started youtube had started
and i didn't know what that was exactly
but knew i could like make
my own things while trying to go on
auditions and do
improv at the people's improv theater on
a weekly basis
and hustle and then all of a sudden
youtube sort of
blew up and my friend and i were making
videos i started working for this
website called my damn channel
and made videos for them for a while and
just got kind of
um ushered into this world without it
being an actual
plan a little bit like yours that you
just sort of follow
the yeses to different things to
different things to different things
and uh spent a couple years in new york
and then moved here like nine years ago
and i've been in los angeles
ever since still trying to figure
everything out
as it goes it never stops trying to
figure it out
no it never stops and i think the
interesting thing about
you which i kept trying to i've been
doing all this research and
and looking up you know your your life
and trajectory
you know everyone is so surprised after
full house that you
be suddenly become this raunchy comedian
uh and a lot of people don't know that
this has just been in your blood
your whole life and i wasn't as raunchy
i think i i was
weird of really weird and a lot of
inappropriate jokes that you can't tell
today
at all right and then from my start
and then i was a guitar act you know uh
which is uh it's good and bad
it was i was doing parodies which is the
lowest form of comedy
and then i started to write more
original songs um
and then every special i've ever done
every show i've ever done you know
there's a lot of music in it
and and it's and the songs are
getting better i'm finding myself to be
a better writer
because a comedy song is not like a
regular song it's right
it's stand up and if it's a good tune
it's it's real special if you can make
that happen
yeah it's a skill it's a totally i mean
like weird al
has been doing parody songs his parodies
minds aren't minor original
adam sandler's hanukkah song when it
first came out
everyone not only was it funny and told
a story that
from a perspective that people hadn't
heard before but it was a good
song like the music quality of it was
great too
right but i think it's interesting now
because
you are involved in social media which
is this new thing that when you're doing
full house you don't have this on set
where in between takes you can go make a
tick tock
or some [ __ ] like that fuller house
we went insane
because we had every age demo was
represented in the cast and there's
48 cast members so it's crazy it never
stopped but i was always
documenting stuff because i had a video
camera because i was the video guy too
so
i was pre youtube that video show was
the first time we ever saw
somebody get hit in the crotch fall down
so right no that's the thing is
america's funniest on videos
is uh youtube before youtube
existed in fact today i'm doing an
interview with
emmy magazine about reality television
because we were
at the forefront of it and then it was
really after a writer's strike
um that that the networks went oh what
are we gonna do now
um okay here's what we'll do we'll do
reality shows and then they started
doing things you know free housewives
right right all reality stuff came in
and unfortunately
when writers were ready to come back and
they settled it put a lot of writers out
of work
because reality had taken over and now
with
what happened with the pandemic uh you
know television again
has gone how are we going to make shows
and let's get ready to make shows in a
year
or in six months but for now hey let's
put
all of our late night shows on zoom or
whatever machine they're using and it
turns out those ratings are higher than
they were before
because people are home yeah everyone
wants to consume
content and it's very for someone that's
been on youtube for so long
watching you know stephen colbert or
john oliver
do what i used to do in 2009 in my
apartment in brooklyn is just a very
it's a weird sense of nostalgia and like
a real humanizing thing to see these
people that we see in such a glossy
format be stripped of that
and be presented same you know
intentions but just
like youtubers in their bedroom but you
can see the same version of them
uh doing it yeah in the same form you
did
because it's all look if you're a
communicator
and a comedian and you're a broadcaster
if you add that component which you are
as well
because you could host anything at all
in the world
if you wanted to or act or whatever you
want to do um
but that is there's nothing more pure
than this
right i agree there's yeah it very
it takes away all the glossy sheen and
it's the reason why youtube
became so successful is because you felt
this uh
intimacy with creators that you didn't
get from television
television had this kind of blocking i
couldn't leave a comment
under an episode of full house you know
but i can go
and watch something online and interact
directly with it or at least feel like
i'm doing that i usually get hurt with
those comments
well now it's interesting what did you
make like a
conscious shift in any way when you saw
social media start to emerge did you did
you think i need to get on instagram or
did someone come to you and say you need
to be on instagram or you need to be on
twitter
or did you kind of see this evolution
and very organic
very organic yeah but there were people
that were conduits to it
a couple friends like uh snapchat for
sure
someone put me on yeah i think it was
believe it or not it was john mayer we
were in a restaurant
and he gave me the name bobster claw and
i went can i even pick my own name what
are you doing
he's branding you for you he branded me
but and it
you know it's just wonderful but you
know and then
um howie mandel and my wife said go on
tick-tock and i went ah
okay and i i enjoy it right now is not
the time i'm not feeling
that kind of joyousness to go make a
silly fun video i'm looking forward to
when we can do that
again um and be silly
and yeah and not have the stress we have
from too much news um because you need
some
you need some news you need to know
what's going on and you can't live on
your citizen app
i don't know if you have that i
definitely have it
and there's a lot going on in my
neighborhood oh my
you just hit a square and go wait a
second
this is an alert a woman chases man with
a stick
yeah and i'm like with a man hurts
uh building with a twig you know some of
the things are a little bit
thank god that's those are the ones i
like
dog poops on fence you live in an area
with much more sticks than i do
apparently it turns out
then we got a few sticks here and there
um okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back
uh i have obviously a lot more questions
for you so we'll be right back with more
not too deep
[Music]
i bet you're sitting on a great idea and
you just
don't have someone to help you out with
turning it into a reality well guess
who's got your
back or your front or wherever you need
support it's squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project
do you want to start a new business do
you want to showcase your work do you
want to publish content or sell products
or more because you know we're all right
now trying to figure out our pivot
squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
get this world-class designers
and the ability to customize just about
anything so
in a few clicks you can easily make a
beautiful website
all by yourself they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time and everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
out of the box so you don't need to know
what that means it just means there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever
you don't even really need to know what
that means because if you do need help
they have
a 24 7 award-winning customer support
squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants
and gyms you know when they everyone
needs help
right now to turn great ideas into
something real so head to
squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10 percent
of your first purchase of a website or
domain again that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
did you know that there's a company
that's mastered the science of sparkle
meet lightbox lab-grown diamonds they
hacked a billion-year process to grow
stunning lab-grown diamond stones in
about two weeks and they're some of the
highest quality stones that exist
they're always near colorless always vs
clarity
always a very good cut and always 800
per
carrot they come in three colors too
white blush pink and soft blue
after they're grown in the lab they're
transformed into gorgeous lab-grown
diamond jewelry
it's beauty meets brain go to lightbox
jewelry dot com slash grace and use code
grace
for 25 off that's lightbox jewelry.com
grace use code grace for 25 off
okay let's get into this
what i i'm so you're also hosting
nashville squares
right and i don't know if that's coming
back because of the situation
in the show but i'm i'm fascinated
um i love game shows love reality tv
love scripted tv
what for you is the major like headspace
difference when you're hosting something
like
uh funny song videos or nashville
squares versus
a fuller house uh well obviously those
are
they're also well i did do a dirty
version of the video show and we're
waiting to find out where it's coming
out
oh that's great yeah so that and we shot
14 of those and um nashville squares was
an offer and a call and they said no
there's no script
you just have to say a couple things and
then just screw around
i went okay and uh and so
i enjoyed that because seeing me host
and i write country music as well as
all kinds of stuff right isn't my dog
licked my balls
um like a country song yeah just for
your listeners yes that is a song
she's not cursing at me or telling me
what her dog did
because that would be confounding yeah
but uh yes my dog lick my balls is a
country song that people just adore
and yeah i have a a a whole lot of
different ones that just came up uh the
newest songs that i have that mean the
most right now there's one that i
closed my last special with which is
called we've got to be kind to each
other
and that dealt with all of the hatred
that i was seeing in the world so
all my stand up and i had a brand new
hour to go to do a special
and then the pandemic hit so i had to
cancel all the road
and when i come back i've got a new hour
and then kobit will be uh
i'm gonna sneeze watch this whoa
bless you in space no one can hear you
sneeze
wow but that's not such a rare thing to
catch on camera thank you for that
opportunity
and you can put any sound you wanna
a song i'm very proud of that i can't
wait to do um and it's called i'm not in
love with my wife's father
um a little bent
a little bit different but it's good to
clarify that for people
who are wondering yeah there's a lot of
assumptions made about you i'm sure and
so you got to really put them to rest
after the aristocrats people thought
that you know there are no limits
to what families can do very fair very
fair
but i i want to get out there and do
this but we can't and we're all going to
have
10 minutes of covered material and we're
also going to have a lot of social
relevant material done whether you do it
or not
um the feeling behind it will be there
yeah well that i mean it must be
exciting and
um a little uh
confusing or different to
know that you had all of this prepared
and then the world makes some dramatic
shifts and
trying to reflect your you know
perspective of it
in real time must be a little bit
challenging to try and
it does make us one and i've been
talking to on my podcast i've been
talking to a lot of
our comedian friends and and we're just
you know dying to get out on the road
now it's not the time
uh it goes without saying right and i'm
not going anywhere until
people don't have to sit six feet apart
and wear a mask
i mean that's that's not comedy that's
like a south park bit
you know right right right um
do you go out and tour i do some live
shows i'm usually with a couple friends
of mine i don't do stand-up it's a very
um scary world for me
but uh the closest i do is kind of like
we do storytelling and sketches and
audience participation things and um
stuff like that and we were supposed to
do some shows um
the last month that got moved to the
fall-ish still waiting to hear kind of
every
everyone's in that weird limbo right now
um but i do want to talk about your
podcast
so you have yeah you have a new podcast
i mean pretty new
right you've been doing it for a few
months now no um i think about a month
oh so a month okay so very it might be
yeah it might be a couple months i don't
know it depends on when this is uh out
in the ethos
i would say weeks yeah for i don't know
so still so still fairly new i do it a
lot
however do you how often is yours out uh
well this podcast is out once a week and
we've been doing this for about six
years this one and then my
best friend um and i have a podcast that
we do once a week that we've been doing
for a year and a half that doesn't have
any guests it's just the two of us i
like that i like that one also
oh thank you but yours is bob saget's
here for you
and the conceit is basically people
you're talking with comedian friends
uh and then other people that call in
for
advice i have people that call a line
a number that's listed up in the uh you
know the menu
on the whatever you're listening to it
on and then i i post on uh
instagram stories and twitter when i'll
be calling
okay so you call i can't call them wow
this is really cool because they don't
know what i'm gonna call
right or if i'm gonna call and so
like a couple days a week i do those
shows sometimes i'll do a
a monologue by myself just how i'm
feeling
um right now i kind of need to talk to
people
yeah what's it been like i mean because
this isn't uh
it's a little it's a little bit it's a
big risk to say i'm just gonna call
cold call people and have conversations
with them
how has it been having human to human
conversations with people
i have it's i find it so rewarding
and once in a while um they'll they
won't be hate
you know those are weeded out
unless someone's trying to uh you know
uh
what do you call it uh troll me troll
you yeah
right so then they're real nice on the
message then you call them and then they
say horrific things but
the edit's so simple so it's hanging up
you know i won't be talked to that way
and i'll probably leave it in
but i like it to be as much live you
know to tape as possible
even though it's not and it's really
wonderful i've talked to
nurses in hospitals that are uh
you know i lost a patient today and then
it's like whoa okay
so this just it it becomes very uh
chameleon lack where i change according
to what i'm
dealing with and then she tells me she's
a social worker also
and how her son is autistic and then i'm
i'm starting to cry and then i get to
make her laugh
with something uh yeah and so for me
that's
and the show was designed
pre-pandemic and then i did two in
studio and then
we couldn't go anywhere right so the
title
meant even more about all the unrest
and unhappiness and dissension that i
was feeling
from everywhere i was touring and
everywhere we looked on the news
everywhere you look there's a hand to
hold on to
but then um that was the design of it
and then i started calling my friends i
had to
and their their long podcasts some of
them are 90 minutes like bill burr
is pretty long and howie mandel and i
had a wonderful
discussion because he's the king of
social distancing
mm-hmm yeah i've bumped that fist before
yeah yep and he he won't be doing that
anymore
i doubt it yeah and i had tiffany
haddish on because i had a connection
with her because i had
i got a teacher in comedy camp at the
laugh factory
wow 16 i mean she was like living in her
car at 18. she
wow he really came from nothing
and wanted to be richard pryor and he's
kind of my one of my idols of my life
and i knew him and loved him and
but it must be cathartic because a lot
of people obviously you're ingrained
in the this very paternal role in all of
our
lives the and a lot of like our teenage
years that are the most like
developmental parts of our lives so
you've always
for all these strangers represented this
father
figure that now you're getting to
actually
be almost a father figure by calling up
these people and emotionally checking in
on them that you're fulfilling the role
that we all have kind of
deemed you as in and i accept it and i
like it
and that's the therapy has paid off
because
uh because at first when i started
coming out in my you know
around 40. um i got
uh i was divorced at like 41 at 42
and then um and i have three wonderful
daughters
uh that are women um and uh
which is comforting that's great i don't
know what that means
uh but um it didn't come out right
i just i meant that they didn't stay
young that's what i had
other people will say that oh what are
you saying
are you saying oh please everybody's
back just relax
uh but um i've had to be careful with
jokes i've done about them over the
years
you know that i really upset my
middle daughter when she was like 16 i
was on an hbo special
and i talked about her thong being like
an eye patch because i was doing laundry
and she goes dad you don't know how much
[ __ ] i had to take for that i'm like oh
i'm really sorry and then i talked about
her cell phone i love verizon i remember
i turned her into a monster
i loved her cell phone and it was
terrible and i've apologized
over and over but um it's it's really
interesting that the the pandemic
caused everybody to
have to be home and have this and and
want to be
soothed so yeah i'm like a dad voice
yeah and it's and i and i like it
because i'm also like
oh bob come on let's let's just get into
it man be dirty you know it's like
be dirty and then i just berate them
which is what they want in the first
place
and so i i can go as r-rated as a person
once but i'm not
whenever anybody ever writes x-rated or
someone's like what are you talking
about why don't you watch
about five of the best comedians that
don't work
clean and just work as they talk they
they're it's not work it's how they talk
but in front of a lot of people
and i'm no dirtier than them i don't
talk usually my stuff's bizarre
it's got squirrels in it you know it's
got animals you know it's like john
oliver's always
when you're watching john oliver he
always will go to an animal to get you
out of the
political mess that he brings up it's an
animal or it's gritty
the mascot it's one of the two oh yeah
do you now check in with your daughters
when you feel like you have
material or conversation that could
affect them negatively
well actually the one that i talked
about her thong um
i was recording a solo podcast
and and she called while i was recording
the solo podcast and i said you want to
go on the podcast and she said sure
and she's on like my i don't know what
episode it was like fourth or fifth
and lara is her name lara
and we talked for an hour and 15 minutes
um wow and it's it
what i love about podcasts and and i'm
like
naturally meant born it's it's an easy
facility
for me but for what you were saying was
people don't know me as
just being who i am right which i don't
which is so interesting about this time
because so many people
would never show the inside of their
homes and so many people would never
uh be human right at the facade of show
business
and you always have to be the big star
and that's true of some people that
don't want to get involved
and i respect and you know
look up to a lot of people that don't
even go on social media
right i had john hamm on um
recently and he doesn't do social media
because he doesn't believe in it
he just thinks it's a thing he doesn't
want to get himself
hooked into he does he just wants to do
the work yeah and he's just a
just a lovely talented wonderful guy
um so i
i i think what i love about and i've
been doing podcasts as a guest
for so long right that it was always a
natural facility
when i used to go on stern all the time
i would always and that's pre-podcast
obviously yeah
it was it started when before he went to
serious i was on his free radio
you know um and we would have really
long conversations
and it was pre his divorce and i had
already gotten divorced
and i had three daughters he had three
daughters and we would talk about
you know he would say he was in the in
the basement watch
on the internet i said if you don't get
off the internet in the basement you're
not going to stay married
that's what you get out of this kind of
yeah no there's a night uh
yeah there must be a nice kind of um
freedom
in the platform in which you're able to
be
unedited you're able to speak freely
you're able to speak without
um expectation of a punchline
all the time which i think at least i
know for myself is why i enjoy it so
much is that the
the level of allowing yourself to be
funny
and also allowing yourself to be real is
a really wonderful balance that i enjoy
a lot more than sitting down and trying
to write out like a youtube video or
something like that that's what's great
about you
that's what's great about and you're in
a small air
of people that don't have a show
produced
to get out yeah sit there with bullet
points and a script and now comes the
part of our show where we ask questions
you know
what do you think of when i say this you
know
but to j you got to be people's friend
yeah and that's what they really want
and
i want i kind of am finding the higher
road of people right now well that's i
think that's very exciting and also
it's very commendable to be able to just
sort of
take down any wall between you and an
audience and like connect
by calling them up directly and having
conversations
it's really strange and then some of the
episodes that i love
is they they know i'm going to call they
they don't believe it's going to happen
but everyone is surprised
and they'll pass the phone around and
some people are
10 people in one apartment yeah i'm
talking to all
economic groups people from all kinds of
walks of life
and those are some of my favorite
conversations and i'll go for a half
hour with the whole family that's great
put the five-year-old on you know yeah
and then the 20-year-old guy i'll get on
he'll want to talk raunchy and then
he'll go i went in the other room it's
okay bob
no no go back i want to talk to your mom
again but
so i am navigating through a parental
yeah you're doing a little bit of family
counseling at the same time
it sounds like really i am but yeah
the thing is they're they're the gift
and they don't
have anybody to talk to one guy was in a
hotel with his mom
and they didn't know where to go because
they didn't have any money
and they were going to leave after
talking to me they were going to leave
the hotel
and go somewhere and they didn't know
where
wow when i was done with that i just
went to the other room
which is like going across town right
now yep and
and uh i just started crying and my wife
said what happened i said i just had the
most
deep conversation that hurts me
um and how many checks can we write
because there's so much that needs help
so
but but that's the i i love it i love it
it took me a long time actually my
therapist actually said to me
it took me a long time to get to a good
therapist i had a bad one for a while
and then i had this amazing one
yeah that's the thing too that i think a
lot of people don't realize is that you
gotta find the right therapist some of
them are not as good as others for you
no they're really bad yeah and there's a
lot of
um i've had a lot of mental health
issues in my family
i've lost two sisters one mental health
issue
and one scleroderma which is hardening
the skin
and so i i mean i got my toe in many
different
areas of trying to help but the mental
health world people are giving people
the wrong meds they don't even give them
the right diagnosis
they tell them they've got one thing and
it's not that right
uh you know you're schizophrenic take
these meds uh and
and they're not they're you know there's
anyway i don't want to get too heavy on
it but everybody
howie mandel and i were talking about it
because he wrote it in his book he said
everybody
everyone has mental illness
some not as strong as others some
not at all because they have it under
control but they have it
and it's how open the the the valve is
on how much you can't handle
and so talking to a good shrink and
my uh what i got out of my person and
some people don't believe in therapy
and some people um and i can understand
that i mean they weren't raised that way
i wasn't raised that way to believe in
it yeah
we had to go to family therapy for my
sister once um
but she was really going through a hard
time and my parents couldn't open
themselves they were good people but
they
they couldn't um there was no acceptance
that they had a part in any of the
problems
and you can't you can't be like that so
um if you're not part of the but i don't
know what the expression is then you're
part of the problem
right right right right but but my
shrink set is no
you this is who you are you do take care
of everybody
take care of your your daughters you
take care of people you love
you you want to do that that's your role
why do you think you do this why do you
like to direct
why do you like to produce stuff
why do you like to more importantly take
care of people that you love why are you
a conduit for so many friends
yeah and then i went i accept
i accept my role and so and
and it really came out in my am i
talking too much about no you're great
this is fascinating
okay thanks it's
not i mean sure but so is anything that
we do
that isn't you know the completely and
utterly selfless
um the but i that's an important thing
to recognize because there's also
some obvious um
like you feel purpose or you feel
whole because you know you
are providing for other people or caring
for other people i get so much from it
yeah and it's crazy that you're only a
month or so into your podcast i'm
excited for you to expand and just see
where you go with this if you're already
you know generating so much joy and you
know just complex conversations with
people
a month in it's and i'm doing it every
monday wednesday friday
wow so this i usually have a
special guest a friend um
and and they're from they're all
different kinds of
people that i just love and um and
some don't like we were talking don't
want to
deal with um the issues at the moment
but can't avoid them
so it's in general terms like jim
gaffigan he's a guy that's been doing
this amazing thing
um with his family and it's it he's
going bonkers not being able to go out
and then the fortunate people that have
movies that can't go and finish
their movie because they've got four
more to make and it's like well you
lucky
yeah and bastard but perspective
but it's uh but taking responsibility
and if you're solid enough as a person
the gift you have is to help other
people yeah
i think that's really to keep it in the
most simple form
a great way to think about it because
it's very easy to get overwhelmed and
be suffocated by your own sense of
helplessness and also be distracted
by your own sense of not being able to
fix everything all at once
and it's impossible when you take the
world in when you when you watch the
news
it's impossible because absolutely and i
i resent
the format that we have allowed and and
that the news
networks have allowed where i feel like
it's not as much and i'm not
calling out anybody because everybody's
it's all about ratings
yeah so they that everybody's it's like
a
a a wrestling match you know but the big
story
we've solved the whole problem after
this yeah
yeah we insured coronavirus and we'll
tell you how
right after this right after this four
commercials about cars for kids
i know i mean kids can't drive um
i might they're gonna have to soon
probably
well that's a perfect segue for my last
set of uh ads for
this episode of not too deep so uh we're
gonna take a quick break as ironic as
that is
and when we get back uh we'll wrap up
with the two
questions that i ask every single guest
that is on the podcast so we'll be right
back with more not too deep
[Music]
right now is a time that all of us are
struggling with
some sort of stress or anxiety or
isolation
or depression and you're not alone we're
all going through
it and if you're curious and something
that can help you out
better help betterhelp offers online
licensed professional counselors
who can help their counselors specialize
in issues like depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
trauma
anger family conflicts lgbtq plus
matters grief
self-esteem and more you can connect
with your counselor in a safe
and private online environment anything
you share is confidential
you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your needs and you get matched
with a counselor in less than 24 hours
and from there you can easily schedule
secure video or phone sessions with your
therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages
i've had friends that use this app and
love it it's
so much especially because you have the
ability to
text with your counselor everything's
super confidential and super convenient
to you wherever you are however you want
to communicate
and if for any reason you're unhappy
with your counselor you can request a
new one at any time
for no additional charge it's an
affordable option
and you guys will get 10 off your first
month of this already affordable option
with the discount code grace
that's better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash grace discount code grace
talk to a therapist online and get help
okay would you buy a t-shirt for fifty
dollars if you knew
it only cost seven dollars to make i bet
you wouldn't
i wouldn't and i'm a betting woman and i
bet you wouldn't and with everlane you
never have to overpay for quality
clothes
they make premium essentials using the
finest materials without traditional
markups
they want you to know what you're paying
for and why so they tell you
they're real costs and they're radically
transparent about every step in their
process
from the materials they use to the
ethical factories that they work with
no matter your style or preference they
have clothes that look better
cost less and last longer because
everlane sells directly to you
their prices are 30 to 50 percent lower
than traditional retailers
that's a great deal they have essentials
like a cotton crew t-shirt that's
exactly what it should be
versatile simple stylish and made from
quality materials
i'm a simple gal and i like simple
nice clothes because i don't take the
best care of my clothes
but with these they're made so well that
they last
so much longer than any of the really
cheapy cheap
stuff that i usually go for and right
now you can check out
our personalized collection at
everlane.com grace
we've picked and chosen some really cool
essentials that maybe you
vibe with i don't know i'm using vibe
i'm so hip and trendy and young
plus you can get free shipping on your
first order so go to everlane e v
e r l a n e dot com slash grace
to go check out our personalized
collection again everlane.com
grace free shipping on your first order
um well i'm gonna ask you some really
hard-hitting questions there's two
that i ask every single guest does on
the podcast uh can i ask you one
question
then how did you come up with the title
for your for this
oh um i've been told this by
women before oh yes yes it's uh people
have done that joke with you right
yes yes yes well the pure innuendo i
mean
if there is a sense of innuendo it
wasn't created solely based on innuendo
i when i first did a friend's podcast
years ago um it was a very
i'm i'm raised in a very uh
english british sort of family
repressed don't talk about feelings kind
of household
uh as adults we're all much more in
touch with their feelings in the way
that we communicate but
i remember doing a friend's podcast like
six or seven years ago and it felt like
a therapy session with like two older
brothers
and it was very overwhelming and it was
a little too
much for me at the time but i understood
the value in it so
i wanted to create the antithesis of
that and do a podcast that was solely
about
nonsense and that's how this it started
with
questions that didn't allow me to get to
know the person that i was talking to in
any way shape or form just
completely nonsensical questions but as
i grow evolve change mature as a person
i find humans like you were saying
infinitely fascinating in in all of
their
weird complexities and so it just
started morphing more into
i don't care to hear only about the
silly stuff
i am fascinated with what's under the
surface so the name isn't as
apt now but it's still
i like it i mean it tells you what it is
we're gonna
we're gonna talk about stuff but we're
not gonna go
so deep that it's gonna uh damage you i
mean because
it's only where you're comfortable right
okay
uh first question is who this
i answer obviously will change on a
regular basis it's not one concrete
answer for a lot of people but who alive
or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at
well alive or dead cold spaghetti i i i
guess
i wouldn't want to throw uh is there
sauce too
it's a it's your choice dealer's choice
well i don't want to hurt anybody
even if they are incredibly evil well
the other
the it's you're also your intention is
up to you it can be a celebratory oh
could it be a teletubby something
that's not real yeah absolutely because
they really got on my nerves so i would
i would just throw it on a teletubby
because i just look at that as marketing
i didn't think that tried to entertain a
child
i don't think any kid came away and said
i miss teletubbies
fair yeah i also feel like that was
rangers power rangers
oh okay okay so you have
two uh sensitive spots in your well my
my first choice would have been hitler
but that you know i think teletubbies a
little less painful
for people to have to hear the word
which i just said anyway
oh no but also i feel like the
a teletubby being showered uh with
spaghetti
is a probable through line that has
happened on that show before
and you know they say that anything you
think of as weird as it might be
has been done which means a teletubby
showering to some people
is hot and i think that they need to see
some
uh some professional help they need they
uh
because until it's two teletubbies
taking a shower
is almost something that is you could
find on the internet if somebody has
done that i guarantee you
that is there is an anime oh i'm sure
uh it's if you think about googling it
it's able to be googled
uh we're gonna move on to the next
question which is
everyone gets asked this to tell us your
worst pant [ __ ] story
or a close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases
or a combination so mine is college
jogging front lawn
got it
mine is
bed flu milk dud
the candy candy size
okay a poodle
a poodle i see i see i see in my mind i
i i such a sweet tooth that i had some
desperate hope that maybe there was a
cure for the flu in milk duds that i
hadn't heard about
what i'm describing is another thing you
could probably find on the internet
i understand now i understand now um
bob we've reached the end of the podcast
i know
i'm gonna be so lonely my wife's working
all day come on
you have another interview after this i
can put it off
um well what can people or what should
people know
about what you're working on you have
your podcasts what else is going on for
you that they might not know about
well uh soon i hope they have an
announcement about uh directing a movie
that'll happen as soon as
we get through this
crazy time um and um
there's another couple television
projects that i'm also
acting as a producer on but it's too
soon to tell it because we don't know
where we are
but the main thing is if they look at
their website they'll see
the tour that will happen when it's safe
to be out
and then i'll be doing a special now
next year that i'll be
doing all this new material which is
really more humanistic than i've ever
been
in my work that's very exciting
it'll be good and in the meantime this
podcast is not an in the meantime for me
because i'll always be doing it i'm not
doing it some people are doing it as a
as a temporary thing because they can't
act right now they can't do this so
oh we'll do a podcast about all right
we're bitter
you know and we're or we're sad and
mine is trying to boost up people and i
i plan to do it anyway it's just a hard
drive for everything else i do so i know
that's what you do you're doing this
for years now my god yeah yeah but yeah
i mean
i have no doubt that you'll get there if
you're this um
enthusiastic about it already i can only
see it
continuing on and getting bigger and
better thank you the one last thing is
normally when we do the podcast in
person
we um give our guest a gift
of personalized fortune cookie but
because we're doing this
digitally i think melissa has a virtual
fortune cookie
um that's personalized to you from
us for making time to chat with us
that's so sweet oh i got it here it is
okay
i'm just downloading it
here it is i'm so excited thank you of
course
it's real everybody it's real look at
that here it is a wise man once said on
his podcast
love right now just means spraying
somebody with hand sanitizer
that's how you love them unfortunately
we just met
so we don't know if we're ready for that
step maybe on the next podcast
yeah what a fortune
it's it's a lot to take in take your
time
process that for the rest of the day as
2020s vernacular says that's a lot to
unpack
yeah yeah exactly didn't hear that in
2019 where'd that come from this is a
i'll be reading this all day
oh good uh where can people follow you
because you are so involved in social
media if they don't already know
i'm just uh it's my uh bob saget
what a mystery it's s-a-g-e-t so that's
where i'm at on
instagram twitter facebook uh the
tick tock uh your grandmother's house
uh stay away from your grandmother's
house by the way this ain't the time
right
no no no no no no and uh and my website
is uh
myname.com no it's not my name it's not
my
name your name here.com but it's my name
yeah so it's all under me because i get
that's the nice thing about
uh being a known person the only nice
thing is
sometimes tables and restaurants
depending on who answers the phone
and then the other thing is uh you get
to
have your websites you get to have all
of your own socials no one can steal
your name
that's good you want to go where it's
like cheers you want to go where nobody
steals your name
yeah exactly exactly couldn't have said
it better
well thank you for spending time with us
and thank you
for um just a wealth of information and
and and i'm very excited for the
conversations that you're having and i'm
glad that we got to chat today
everyone so sweet you're so sweet you're
so kind
trying trying the best that i can right
now you're wonderful
that's very thank you and we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music